to who would you put at the top when he
said there's a lot of countries that
want to take us down who's at the top is
china at the top sean has always been at
the top patrick has always been at the
top yeah china china
you know people say do you think we're
going to war china
you all said that to me
and said you know first of all what does
modern day warfare look like to you
do you think it's propaganda yes do you
think that cyber warfare yes do you
think is
manipulation social media yes currency
economy
so we're already at war
right
so don't don't judge war as troops on
the ground right hot war
right so once you own infrastructure you
own supplies and everything how can we
even go to war we can't even
we can't even fill up our tanks in in
jets because we're buying
our our gases and oil from where
russia
our enemies
we're we're making our enemies stronger
that's what we're doing and us losing
afghanistan and now china moving in
you don't think they have the the energy
supply it needs in northern afghanistan
supply their china
there's interest there
and they'll go to war for it
and let me ask you this so taiwan
that's our allies right so we we we left
our allies in afghanistan right we left
india now surrounded geographically by
the middle east now they're in a state
of deficit
right so now
who's going to protect you know who's
going to take our borders now
because we don't have eyes and ears in
the middle east anymore
you know afghanistan was a hub that we
use to get eyes and ears into to middle
east so we can flex where we needed to
that we can control the region stabilize
the region now you have a country that's
ran by terrorists
and is known
to train terrorists in that that country
and now they're the richest
probably one of the richest countries so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]